[Musique]
bienvenue dans le duel des éditos
l'émission de débat qui analyse chaque
semaine l'actualité politique au
sommaire emmanuel macron le président
sortant a atteint 46% d'opinions
favorables dans un récent sondage
largement au dessus de ses prédécesseurs
à la même période après un quinquennat
ponctuée par les crises gilet jaune
qu'ovide que penser du bilan des manuels
macro comment expliquer une telle
popularité faut-il croire les sondages
réponse dans le débat de la semaine
alexis poulin et jacques de guillebon
vous livreront ensuite dans le monde
d'après les bruits de couloir leurs
indiscrétions qui feront l'actualité
politique des jours à venir mais d'abord
dans l'acte eu des éditos contre attaque
de la classe politique alors que le
tempo du début de la campagne est donné
par eric zemmour depuis plusieurs
semaines michel barnier valérie pécresse
marine le pen ou encore emmanuel macron
tente de reprendre la main sur le thème
de l'immigration
référendum coup de vis sur les visas du
maghreb chacun y va de sa tactique alors
messieurs première question selon vous
un référendum sur l'immigration c'est
suffisant pour rameuter les électeurs
bonjour alexis ce jour jacques alors un
référendum sur l'immigration sera t-il
suffisant je ferai une réponse de
normand c'est à dire ça dépend pour qui
eric zemmour ne parle que de ça depuis
le début de sa campagne non campagne
mais il est passé de 3 à 13 % et
commerce est fascinant c'est assez
fulgurant on a rarement vu ça en france
il connaît même s'il est connu depuis
des années mais pour d'autres choses
marine le pen en revanche il ya comme
une antériorité sur la question elle ne
fait que chuter alors que c'est elle qui
a présenté son référendum il ya trois
jours et ça l'a fait chuter encore dans
les sondages c'est étonnant évidemment
il ya une question qui se pose sur la le
traitement médiatique à cette conférence
de presse de marine le pen qui a été peu
relayé finalement alors que c'est un
projet qu'elle porte depuis 2019 alors
que ce on peut pas lui en vouloir de
travailler sur ce sujet c'est un sujet
qu'elle connaît et ce référendum on voit
bien que il est en train de faire son
chemin
au delà du racing en national et d'eric
zemmour puisque la droite traditionnelle
est en train aussi de voir comment le
faire au delà de rameuter des électeurs
qui était la question je pense que ce
référendum il permet aussi de dire
écoutez il faut dépassionner ce débat le
débat sur l'immigration c'est un débat
technique c'est un débat nécessaire et
pour ça il faut que les français
n'acceptent et un référendum pourquoi
pas ça permettrait de faire avancer la
loi et d'éviter de la politique
partisane là où on doit avoir une
politique
finalement adapté aux réalités parce
qu'on voit bien que les chiffres bah ça
ne colle pas sur les occulter avec les
obligations de quitter le territoire
français elles ne sont jamais respectées
quasiment 1 0 2% et puis à la crise des
visas qui vient de s'ouvrir avec
emmanuel macron et gérald darmanin qui
décident de durcir parce que évidemment
on rentre dans la campagne électorale et
donc c'est maintenant qu'on s'occupe de
ce sujet là oui mais si vous pensez que
ça va être dépassionner le débat je
pense que c'est un petit peu optimiste
mais en revanche je pense que ces
politiques se sert du référendum
justement pour ne pas assumer eux-mêmes
la question directement et même marine
le pen recul un petit peu là dessus et
on va écouter en fait le ce que disait
marine le pen dans sa conférence de
presse
élue présidente de la république je
présenterai aux français un référendum
où la question sera simple
approuvez vous le projet de loi c 2 i
projet de loi citoyenneté identité
immigration qui comprendra un plan
complet de maîtrise de l'immigration à
certain nombre de grands principes
seront ainsi constitutionnaliser comme
la maîtrise de l'entrée des étrangers
l'éloignement des étrangers condamnés
pour crimes ou délits graves ou ceux qui
portent atteinte à l'ordre public la
priorité nationale la protection par le
chef de l'état de l'identité et du
patrimoine de la france
l'interdiction de tout communautarisme
le principe de l'interdiction des
régularisations de clandestins
marine le pen pense que c'est une
question simple mais c'est quand même
listé une dizaine de choses et la
question encore moins simple que ça si
on sait que pour faire un référendum sur
ce sujet il faudrait qu'elle fasse un
référendum d'abord pour changer la
constitution parce qu'en fait ça ne
rentre pas cette question la soul est il
selon lui constitue la liste dans ce qui
est autorisé par le référendum sous la
vème république et savait déjà été happé
par le conseil constitué dont 93 il
faudrait passer au delà de quinze
instance supranationale ce qui je pense
est une très bonne très bonne idée mais
il faut encore faut-il alors le faire il
y est bien le problème alors c'était une
promesse un des modèles macron déjà
aussi de dire qu'il allait s'attaquer à
ce sujet là avant la fin du quinquennat
sur les obligations de quitter le
territoire français on voit qu'il en est
loin et puis il ya la question
européenne aussi gérald darmanin et tout
le gouvernement ne veulent une
harmonisation du droit d'asile au niveau
européen parce que l'europe souffre du
principe de dublin c'est à dire que tout
demandeur d'asile doit d'abord être
traités par le pays où il fait la
demande et puis après si elle est
refusée ils purent faire une demande en
france ou ailleurs et aujourd'hui
l'europe essaie d'organiser justement
une harmonisation de ce droit là pour
éviter que dublin ne continue de
persister et gérer ce problème qui ne
fait que commencer un problème
migratoire important et et pourtant
les résultats sont sont faibles des
politiques européennes et des politiques
nationales on l'a vu au delà de la crise
de la première crise migratoire dès 2014
ça ne fait que continuer on parle
maintenant de démographie aussi de
risques climatiques qui feront que il y
en aura davantage de migrants
climatiques encore et on a l'impression
que la cedh ne serait-ce que obliger les
pays du maghreb à
récupérer leurs ressortissants est un
problème on le voit ça a créé des
tensions diplomatiques il ya toujours
une très mauvaise volonté de leur part
vis-à-vis de la france dans ces pays du
maghreb sur cet été sur les routes sont
toujours refusés et là on sent qu
emmanuel macron le fait aussi de manière
assez électorale y sera je pense et même
si gérald darmanin s'agite sur le sujet
depuis depuis des mois un point sans pas
produit grand chose
mais bref la question du meilleur son et
plus généralement de vie que celle du
droit d'asile en aura l'occasion d'en
reparler c'est assez étonnant qu'elle
soit totalement devenue centrale dans le
débat français enfin oui complètement et
c'est clairement un des pivots de cette
élection présidentielle qui va venir on
l'a vu d'ailleurs avec la crise afghane
immédiatement et mme nelles macron avait
parlé de crise migratoire donc ça va
nous faire
[Musique]
place au débat de la semaine un
président sortant à 46% d'opinions
favorables à sept mois de la
présidentielle
on n'avait pas vu ça depuis françois
mitterrand en 1994 emmanuel macron non
seulement populaire mais aussi en tête
de tous les sondages sur l'élection de
2022 malgré plusieurs crises le bilan du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro est il bon
ou mauvais son succès s'explique t il
par un manque d'adversaires crédible par
la sortie de crise sanitaire qui
approche mais commençons le débat avec
une question jacques de guillebon et
alexis boulin un président adepte du en
même temps est-ce que ce n'est
finalement pas ce que veulent les
français
je crois pas que c'est ce que veulent
les français on a vu le succès du débat
mélenchon zemmour avec plus de 4
millions de téléspectateurs on voit les
sondages aussi qu'ils plébiscitent un
ces candidats qui sont là pour remettre
les idées politiques sur la table et
dire que la politique c'est une affaire
d'idées et des idées sont importantes
emmanuel macron je crois que le en même
temps ça le sert d'abord lui c'est un
président qui gouverne avec les sondages
avec les enquêtes d'opinion il veut
plaire à tout le monde tout le temps en
faisant des politiques en plus
impopulaire des réformes extrêmement
impopulaire et donc il les regarde la
courbe de sondage pour donner du lest
pour toucher un coup les jeunes sur les
réseaux sociaux un coup les policiers
faire des cadeaux on a vu il a lancé sa
campagne à marseille au début du mois de
septembre avec le chéquier à la main et
il continue donc je sais pas si c'est ce
que veulent les français mais
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui permet à
emmanuel macron d'exister c'est de
n'avoir aucune colonne vertébrale
idéologique et donc de s'adapter
perpétuellement à l'opinion est de
rassembler oui c'est ça c'est davantage
un centriste c'est que vous pouvez
rassembler autour de vous sans clivé
alors que les autres sont obligés de
découper le en morceaux électoraux le
schéma emmanuel lafont est peut-être le
prison qui correspond à ses 23 25% de
bloc bourgeois on pourrait dire français
pragmatiques sont quasiment devenus des
anglo saxons vous rendez vous à dire
c'est à dire des gens qui veulent juste
que la croissance fonctionne qu elle
arrive que le chômage baisse c'est ce
qui se passe et je ne trouve pas qu'il
ait fait de réformes aussi impopulaire
que vous le dites en fait celui dont a
fait les retraites il a repoussé vincent
ya pas qu il y avait eu déjà le droit du
travail dès qu'il est arrivé il ya eu la
réforme de la sncf qui était demandé par
l'union européenne ue et eu un bras de
fer avec la sncf donc là et puis la
réforme des retraites certes mis en
pause phare le kobe dont on voit bien
que c'est quelque chose qu'il veut
réenclencher la réforme encore des
allocutions des allocutions pardon
chômage ou là par décret il veut rendre
plus difficile l'obtention d'allocations
alors même que les voyants ne sont pas
forcément tous au vert avec une
inflation qui est en train d'exploser
donc on voit bien que ils braquent les
français et puis je trouve pas tant que
ça soit le quoi qu'il en coûte la servie
en fait d'une version et demi ils ont
déversé de 100 milliards en fait sur la
france et tout le monde en est content
et ça permet de aux gens de ne pas
sentir le les mesures des réformes que
vous que vous avez cités aux fêtes nef
et je pense que le français est pour
l'instant rassurés par ce président là
parce que la personne en face et
puissent venir le alors c'est je pense
est à l'heure parce que pour moi un imac
rond c'est le président de la violence
violence symbolique mais violence réelle
je vais rappeler quand même sur les
mouvements des gilets jaunes les les
chiffres qui font peur
4439 blessés et 24 et bornier 5 qui ont
eu les deux mains arrachées plus de
12000 107 personnes qui ont été
interpellées en six mois seulement avec
10000 placé en garde à vue 2000
condamnation 313 enquête pour des
soupçons de violences policières qui ont
été ouvertes et des ailes bd plus de
douze mille neuf cent cartouches sont
fait tirer ça ça s'appelle de la
répression d'état il a été extrêmement
violent dans cette gestion d'une crise
sociale et il continue aujourd'hui la
réforme de l'assurance chômage qu'est ce
qu'on fait dans l'est dans les pôles
emploi on va mettre en place des
politiques de sécurité pour les pauvres
gens qui viennent et qu'ils ne vont pas
comprendre ce qui se passe et qui
risquerait de devenir violent donc cette
violence elle s'impose sur les français
et en plus on prépare déjà une réponse
violente à ce qui va être là mais le
mécontentement de d'ailleurs tout à fait
légitime de ces français touchés par ces
politiques je vais pas défendre emmanuel
macron évidemment mais je trouve qu'ils
trouvent toujours le moyen en fait de
contourner ça aujourd'hui vous savez une
crise du gaz il va faire un chèque
énergie vadis trouvé ça tous les fruits
elle c'est notre argent souvenez vous
quand il est sorti de visa sur notre
argent sous les ponts il est sorti de la
crise et gilet jaune avec son grand
débat après et en incitant toutes les
entreprises à offrir une prime de 1000
euros à chaque salarié il s'en est très
bien sorti j'ai entendu ce que vous avez
dit j'ai traversé toute la france j'ai
parlé avec tout le monde et il en est
sorti en aviesan mais sans grand mal
après je tiendrai juste à relativiser en
fait cette popularité qu on lui dit
avoir elle est très grande popularité
par rapport à françois hollande
évidemment ouais et à nicolas sarkozy
qui sont les deux présidents les plus
détestés durant leur mandat de la vème
république mais j'aimerais qu'on voit
aussi les présidents précédents ouais de
gaulle évidemment jusqu'à mitterrand
même les terrains sous ses deux mandats
et chirac aussi qu'il était bien rentré
au tournoi de 50 voire plus de 51 f1
demande à tous les deux ailes du
maquereau et 10 points en dessous et on
a l'impression que c'est prodigieux oui
alors que c'est pas prodigieux du tout
il est toujours autour des 30%
péniblement il monte à 40
me il ya des sondages un sondage qui
date de juin qui disait qu'il ya plus de
6 français sur 10 qui ne souhaitent pas
qu'il se représente donc on peut faire
dire à peu près tout sondage clairement
il même s'il pense ne pas activer parce
qu'il est centriste il clive forcément
et il pousse le débat aux extrêmes d'une
certaine façon la radicalité elle est là
parce qu'il est radical lui dans sa
façon de gérer les affaires l'auto
l'autocrate macron qui s'est dévoilée à
l'aune de la crise du coc vide tout
gérer en conseil de défense sous le
sceau du secret défense c'est pas ça la
démocratie française le fait qu'il a
toujours à peu près telles que celle ci
aussi en partie moi je sais attendant
les
rassure mais je sais pas rassurant parce
que derrière c'est quoi c'est la
négation du parlement que soit le sénat
où l'assemblée nationale c'est le
gouverner par décrets on en connaissait
le 49-3 évidemment et puis gouverner
seul sur tout et ça pourquoi cet homme
qui a été élu très mal face à marine le
pen pense qu'il peut gouverner seul et
qu'il est le seul à avoir l'alpha et
l'oméga de la pensée politique et que ce
qu'il fait est bon pour le pays il est
bon pour les plus riches on l'a vu c'est
le président des riches lisf a été
supprimé mais aujourd'hui l'inflation
qui est la la la hausse de l'énergie
c'est les plus pauvres qui vont le payer
bien entendu mais encore faudrait-il
qu'il y ait en face de lui une
opposition sur et qui les choses à
proposer et pour l'instant autant à
l'extrême gauche c'est à gauche que la
droite et l'extrême droite ya non
seulement pas de personnalité sauf
peut-être jean luc mélenchon et pierrick
scénographe mais surtout pas de
programme allait opposer notamment sur
les questions économiques et sur la
gestion du pays alors mon avis les
français surtout en sortant de cette
crise un an et demi ont besoin de
quelque chose qui les rassure ont besoin
de permanence sont nés le conservateur
qu'on imagine et envie de le reconduire
comme un peu pour être le barack obama
français jeu ce que je ne souhaite
vraiment mais c'est ça semble ressembler
et pour l'instant personne ne peut venir
contester
sans son autorité sa popularité surtout
son son côté ça va fonctionner avec moi
je crois qu'il est soutenu à bout de
bras par un système politico médiatique
les sondages notamment mais aussi le
fait que le jeu politique permet à la
5ème les institutions d'exister comme ça
et de faire toutes ses promesses tous
ces cadeaux avec l'argent des français
aujourd'hui les finances publiques c'est
une catastrophe bruno le maire a le
droit de faire de la dette comme jamais
parce que bruxelles a dit qu'on mettait
entre parenthèses l'orthodoxie
budgétaire mais il se sera pas le cas
dans quelques mois donc là on est en
train de préparer le pire avec des
réformes terrible que ce soit sur
l'assurance chômage que ce soit sur la
réforme des retraites et en matière de
santé et mme nelles macro un bilan
catastrophique c'est plus de 5700 lee
qui ont fermé en 2020 au coeur de la
crise qu vide oui précédent mais s'il
faut pondérer il ya comme des animations
ont été ouverts oui ils sont 35 à 38 ans
dix ans en fait de deux lits fermés et
on devrait changer leur système
ambulatoire mais c'est certain que oui
on est en train de déshabiller la france
y est peu d'investissements on est
parfaitement d'accord il a ils ont tenu
à bout de bras l'économie dans cette
dans cette crise voilà et il n'ya pas
n'y a pas de penser à long terme c'est
certain et on peut le voir aussi en
matière diplomatique comme avec ces
histoires de sous marins on n'entend pas
macron il n'y a pas de politique
générale on sait pas qui sont les alliés
de la france on sait pas où ça va du
tout je suis parfaitement d'accord avec
vous on sait il est totalement
européiste et en ça ils l'appliquent
absolument à la lettre ce qu'on lui
demande de faire il est en train de
vendre à la découpe les bijoux de
famille en france on l'a vu ça a
commencé avec alstom et ça a continué et
ça va le faire qu'empirer c'est quand
même incroyable d'avoir le ministre du
numérique cedrico qui est fière de poser
avec le président de cisco en disant
qu'il va parler de souveraineté
numérique cisco c'est quand même le
provider de l'année c'est l'outil qui
espionne à peu près tous les présidents
et les chefs d'état européens et ça
continue donc il est il est là pour
faire de du marché faire du profit
ouvrir la financiarisation des secteurs
qui étaient jusqu'à présent fermés que
ce soit l'éducation que ce soit le grand
âge pour permettre à des fonds de
pension blackrock ou d'autres de faire
de l'argent là où la france était encore
un peu protégé avec un état social ne
sombrez pas tout à fait dans le
complotisme non plus chaque lundi
l'audience mais là dessus c'est une
vidéo et un projet c'est un projet oui
c'est un projet parce que c'est un livre
l'esprit ne l'a pas forcément pour eux
faire de l'argent à ces fonds de pension
l'a directement en tout cas je pense pas
qu'il est désert au dîner qu'il a à
versailles chaque année avec deux le
gratin de la finance mondiale voyez bien
entendu mais ce qui est amusant c'est
que vous regardez les manuels mcmahon
était l'homme qui soi-disant avait pas
de programme on est juste un projet mais
il ya une école de journalisme qui a
listé pas comme toutes les provisions
qu'il avait fait et sur 300 propositions
vous en avez 241 qu'il n'a pas tenues
claire qui est un absolu heures à peine
une cinquantaine et qui sont les
propositions faites d'ailleurs en plus
assez simple comme supprimer le
sfc des choses comme ça qu'il a fait
mais son programme en fait il n'a pas
appliqué et je pense pas qu'il ait
l'intention de l'appliquer à bas avec
lesquels il converse d'une grande
réforme comme celle des retraites
peut-être qu'il aurait même sans doute
pas le temps de terminer moi ce que je
ne comprends pas avec cette popularité
putatif dans les sondages des malades
macron sait comment les français peuvent
encore lui faire confiance
il n'a fait que mentir depuis le début
et il continue aujourd'hui sur la crise
sanitaire il avait dit pas de passes
sanitaire vous verrez ce ne sera pas
pour les activités du quotidien pas
après le 15 novembre or là on va avoir
le pass inter peut-être jusqu'en 2022 il
avait dit dans son livre révolution
qu'on ne pouvait pas vivre sous un état
d'urgence permanent c'est ce qu'il fait
depuis 19 mois donc il passe son temps à
mentir aux français ouvertement et
pourtant les français continuent de
faire confiance à certains français et
là je ne comprends pas vraiment il ya
quelque chose de la dissonance cognitive
et qui fait comment peut-on avoir un
président aussi menteur et aussi
soi-disant populaire qui continue à
faire des réformes qui maltraitent ce
pays à longueur de temps et qui est dans
le mépris total c'est parce que je
reviens encore une fois à mon avis à
faible bourgeois qui vous en êtes
rassurés parce qu' edouard philippe et
amis aussi adulé par les français
absolument lors qu'il a menti de la même
façon face auquel il avait un programme
évidemment et la même politique et ça
reste encore le seul homme politique
préféré des français donc il faut bien
croire que ces deux hommes là rassure
une part des français il ya besoin de
cette politique libérale dont elle pense
que ça va peut se perpétuer longtemps et
qu'elle fois ce ketch et le mais le
visage sous le cerisier incroyable c'est
qu'ils sont très peu d'aidés être
gagnant de ce quinquennat malin pour 25%
c'est suffisant c'est suffisant pour
gagner en fait c'est son socle on va
dire mais le ruissellement n'a pas eu
lieu avec la suppression de l'sf
l'ifi l'impôt sur le foncier on peut
tout à fait léviter facilement avec
quelques montages juridiques tout ça est
fait non pas pour aider mais pour
remettre les finances publiques à plat
et la dette qui arrivent et c'est là où
je voudrais en venir c'est que même
quand on est le bloc bourgeois et qu'on
aime ou on soutient emmanuel macron il a
une politique catastrophique en matière
de finances publiques ce que ne ferait
pas un dirigeant de droite là on aurait
plutôt une austérité on ferait attention
à ce qui se passe peut-être parce qu'en
réalité les amendes allant de le faire
parce que l europe derrière celle qui
est exactement te redonner les moyens
mais c'est vrai que c'est mon à l'envers
ce sont ses ministres de droite bruno le
maire et edouard philippe anciennement
emmanuel macron ils ont ce plutôt à
droite qu'il faut une politique de
keynésianisme de dépenses publiques
exact et la gauche qui leur reproche ça
vous par exemple ça c'est étonnant qu'on
se retrouve avec ce cette inversion
et c'est encore une fois c'est le même
temps des manuels macron sait il prend
l'omelette s'il vous plaît de jouer
selon la célèbre formule et garde le
centre et gagne 31 aussi qu'est ce que
c'est
[Musique]
direction le monde d'après chaque
semaine jacques de guilbaut et alexis
poulain vous livrent leurs bruits de
couloir leurs indiscrétions leur analyse
qui vont faire l'actualité politique de
demain on commence par vous jacques une
primaire de la droite qui va se faire
entre militants en loucedé bonne ou
mauvaise idée
oui elle se fait en loucedé 7 cette
primaire qui n'est plus une prime est en
fait qu il a dénoncé la désignation d'un
candidat du grand parti de droite sont
les républicains mais avec des candidats
qui ne sont même plus dans ce parti sont
aidés bertrand valérie pécresse et qui
en asie pourrait réserver des surprises
parce qu'il faut pas se méfier de l air
c'était vraiment le parti gaulliste dans
le sens le plus pur du parti c'est le
plein de machinerie à l'intérieur par
essence et michel barnier qui tient à
mon avis les caciques du parti il est
soutenu par les jeunes eux république
est en grande partie il se pourrait que
ce soit lui qui sortent vainqueurs
surprise au sol et qui sortent de ce
parti ce qui serait on devine très
mauvaise idée pour eux mais peu importe
et autre chose c'est la candidature
d'eric zemmour en fait avec que certains
comme françois xavier bellamy
on soutiennent
deux sets ce n'est plus une primaire
n'est en tout cas qui suppose que eric
zemmour ferait partie du camp de la
droite et qu'il aurait le droit de
concourir au milieu des autres c'est
parce que dit thierry jacob yang clouzot
petite allemande est totalement
contradictoire là dessus christian le
pardon à la ba oui c'est assez étonnant
de voir ce parti se recroqueviller comme
ça et d'essayer de faire des deals de de
coin de table pour ce congrès on verra
comment ça se passe moi je voulais
parler dans ce monde d'après bas de la
primaire écolo à eux élevés qui a choisi
son grand gagnant grand gagnant pas
vraiment 51,03 % pour yannick jadot et
sandrine rousseau candidats six
candidats surprises je ne suis pas déçu
je trouve que les verts ont voté plus de
cent mille votes 122 mille inscrits à
cette primaire il y à l'émergence de
cette personnalité politique qui était
inconnu jusqu alors sandrine rousseau à
l'écoféminisme le walk matin midi et
soir et des citations formidable en
disant mais comment oses-tu faire
obstacle à l'avènement de sandrine
rousseau alice coffin qui s'adresse à
yannick jadot et est très déçue sandrine
rousseau et je pense qu'elle n'a pas dit
son dernier mot
qui disait que les courbes était en
train de se croiser à une semaine près
je gagnais donc elle pense je crois
avoir gagné d'une certaine façon et il a
effectivement gagné puisque en
popularité elle n'existait pas avant
cela maintenant elle est connue elle
défend une certaine idée de l'écologie
et je crois que ça va être très
difficile pour ceux qui ont voté
rousseau de se ranger derrière yannick
jadot et de rester discret et je crois
que sandrine rousseau même si elle a dit
qu'elle serait tout à fait loyal dès
qu'elle ferait campagne pour yannick
jadot a déjà des idées pour la presse et
de questions à ce sujet là on pouvait me
répondre pour vous en fête ses cent
vingt mille personnes qui ont voté vous
croyez que ce sont tous des militants
écologistes ou est ce qu'il y ait plus d
armée de trolls qui se sont inscrits et
donc ça ne représenteraient pas de tant
de personnes et deuxième question si oui
ce sont vraiment des militants
écologistes qui ont voté donc soixante
mille personnes où ça continue pour
sandrine rousseau pour cette ligne etc
aux féministes dont j'ai toujours pas
compris ce que ça voulait dire non mais
peut-être un jour qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pour le gauche est ce qu'il ya un
changement profond dans la gauche ce que
le oui qui sont en train de gagner
est-ce que ça gagne les autres partis
dont sont gérées les filles où le parti
spéciaux ne crois pas non non je pense
qu'il ya eu effectivement une partie
troll mais qui est minoritaire je pense
que les gens qui ont voté a été
majoritairement de sensibilité
écologiste ou de gauche on va dire et
c'est vrai que c'est pas énorme 122000
on n'est pas donc c'est beaucoup
effectivement mais de là à près par les
d'avènement de sandrine rousseau de
parler aussi nous sommes en capacité
maintenant de gérer le pays c'est ça va
très loin après sur sur ce courant là
c'est pas un cours en f1 c'est un
courant plus tôt qui vient des états
unis et d'ailleurs on a défendu les
minorités c'est la façon de voir aussi
comment la société est divisée en
cluster on peut dire ça mais en sous
groupes qui se reconnaissent comme tel
et qui essaye d'avoir chacun leur lutte
d'où l'intersexualité on sait toutes les
luttes qui convergent et je trouve que
c'est c'est étonnant de voir que ce
discours arrive à prendre il ya sur un
principe générationnel beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont assez peu à ce discours
là pour les partis de gauche du
traditionnel non je crois pas que ça va
devenir un courant majoritaire c'est un
concept qui n'ont pas besoin de me
remettre en cause non je crois pas
d'accord en tant mieux c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais peut-être qu'il est que
christiane taubira qui avait incarné
saab de cuillé oui depuis longtemps fait
c'est la première fois qu'ils se
trouvent une candidate même si elle n'a
pas gagné exactement qui incarne
réellement ses idées qui les portent
officiellement même si jean luc
mélenchon a essayé de les circonvenir un
petit peu les faire venir vers lui même
si aussi hidalgo
pense la même chose après qu'est-ce
qu'on peut prédire comme comme avenir à
yannick jadot justement ce qui l'a pas
ce ce socle électoral complet on de
seebrook ils vont les apporter le cadeau
des besoins des drags et je sais ce
qu'il va pouvoir éliminer anne hidalgo
vers une fusion la vraie question c'est
ça qu'est ce qui va se passer entre
yannick jadot et anne hidalgo parce que
les deux sont sur le même segment
clairement à la social écologie comme il
l'appelle ça reste du maquereau nice
mais aussi d'une certaine façon en même
temps où on n'en fait plus yannick jadot
bon évidemment puisque c'est un tout qui
englobe rien et l'emploi yannick jadot
qui qui qui au medef a expliqué qu'on
peut faire de la croissance verte donc
il est compatible avec tous évidemment
il n'est pas du tout dans la la
radicalité supposé de sandrine rousseau
ou la bifurcation écologique que propose
jean luc mélenchon exactement comme anne
hidalgo d'une certaine façon
or yannick jadot il est député européen
il n'a pas un bilan aussi délicat à
défendre que anne hidalgo qui est comme
très critiqué à paris et c'est clair
qu'il pourrait prendre beaucoup
d'électeurs de déçus du ps de voir que
le ps choisit hidalgo comme championne
pour les représenter des gens qui
viendraient aussi déçu du maquereau
nisme en disant que ce président n'a pas
fait assez pour l'écologie il n'est pas
assez à gauche pour beaucoup de
maquereaux nisme de la première heure il
arrive à récupérer à droite qu'il a
perdu à gauche je conserve mes forces et
vergallo je voudrais se retrouver chez
jeannot je pense que tu es un peu
optimiste pour la gauche qui à mon avis
il représente un bloc de 30% maximum en
france aujourd'hui qui est divisée entre
deux candidats rivaux coups de cris là
et je pense qu'elle est mal parti qui
n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
nouvelle pour la france mais si on en
revient à la droite enfin si on parle de
sandrine rousseau rousseau pardon
excusez moi c'est un fait mais voilà que
je suivais et d'eric zemmour de l'autre
côté il ya quand même 7 cette question
de la radicalisation corinne on parlait
tout à l'heure on y vient pour la risée
ce débat français on n'en est pas sorti
et les partis qui sont au milieu qui
étaient les anciens partis de
gouvernement se trouve fort mal en point
l'esprit sont ni le centre de macron ni
des partis radicaux comme les attendait
les noms ont guère de propositions à la
personne je sais pas si les français
attendent des partis radicaux je crois
qu'on est aussi dans une phase de la
campagne en pré campagne où c'est
important je crois de secouer un peu les
idées de sortir du jus de cerveau est de
dire on va parler quand même de vrais
sujets et on va oser dire les choses
après dans une deuxième phase ce sera
des projets construits chiffres et on
pourra pas faire ce genre de choses et
là les partis traditionnels auront toute
latitude pour faire ce qu'ils savent
faire ils ont des commissions ils
travaillent ils ont déjà je pense avec
quelques sessions de retard et que ça
fait longtemps que les français ne
votent plus pour un programme d'ailleurs
si on regarde oui c'est vrai à une
élection présidentielle française est ce
qu'on n'a jamais voté pour un programme
je crois pas non en 1981 je pense que
personne ne voulait le programme de
mitterrand s'applique heureusement et on
n'a pas besoin de programmes les gens
vont voter pour un personnage qui les
fascine et y en a pas beaucoup dans
cette élection on verra comment et bien
on va voir ça évidemment ce qui va se
passer en 2022 et d'ici là on se donne
rendez vous à la prochaine au revoir
c'est la fin du duel des éditos vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur notre site rt france point tv
et en podcast sur toutes les plateformes
vous pouvez également réagir dans les
commentaires et sur les réseaux sociaux
via le hashtag ldd eux à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau duel des
éditos
[Musique]